this is bryan dolby reporting from the
ftth council event in munich where I'm
delighted to be joined by our president
Chris Holden who's just attended a major
press conference Chris give us some of
the highlights afternoon Brian will
highlights this year the fibers the home
is still growing so this is our annual
panorama that we always put out and the
first thing we do is look at the world
and actually we have new two new
contenders there so we have Canada and
Malaysia that have joined the ranks
which is great it's always nice to have
new people join it but more
significantly probably we find United
Arab Emirates with fifty five percent
penetration and now in second position
they shot right up to second position in
the world ranking which is quite
incredible and are you encouraged by any
aspects of the European statistics so
the European statistics are showing the
still growth interestingly most of the
growth is in homes past rather than
homes connected but I have to say I'm a
little disappointed there's no new
countries joining the ranking in the
European elements what we are seeing is
some movements so we see Norway move
closer to the top and we're also seeing
that Scandinavian a under a little bit
of risk from eastern parts of Europe as
they go further up the list and of
course towards the bottom of the list as
we often see for the west of Europe we
have France and we have Italy and still
disappointingly we have three other
countries that is Germany UK that and
sorry in Spain that haven't quite made
that list yet but Spain actually is
progressing very well so they're very
close so we expect them to join that
ranking very very shortly just refresh
our memory on what is the criteria for
getting on the list how do you make the
grade yes I guess that's fair comment so
so the criteria is the fact this is
about penetration figures so what we
consider is we take the country has to
have at least 200,000 homes parson
population and then the fact that we're
looking at at least a one-percent
penetration so the minimum bar is one
percent now we're here in Munich at your
main event of the year despite the
weather it's absolutely packed down
there you must be absolutely delighted
with the turnout we're really delighted
we really are and with this weather we
were a little worried but actually we've
managed 3,300 plus people that means
it's a new record for us we've probably
got another ten percent on what we had
last year so it means we really are
firmly the number 15 at home council
event in the world that's fantastic and
what are the sort of some of the main
things that you're seeing this year so
this on the products and the technology
but a lot on things like financing like
how do you build a network what are the
benefits to the public how do you
encourage more people to take on homes
past homes connected and by the service
okay Chris well great congratulations
thank you very much this pleasure ftth
connects the world when are you getting
connected ladies and gentlemen welcome
to Munich for the ninth edition of the
ftth conference creating a brighter
future